war is horrible but let's be honest we
all enjoy watching massive armies clash
with each other
the brutal close combat swords fighting
and amazing strategies that turn the
tide of wars excite us right absolutely
hence in the spirit of war and combat
today's video focuses on titles that
belong to the action and historical
fantasy genre with emphasis on their
impressive medieval aesthetics so
without further ado let's jump right in
with beyond the heavens now if you had
the chance to watch John woos Red Cliff
and had a chance to play Dynasty
Warriors in its many sequels then beyond
the heavens should be your cup of tea
the story is based on a period in the
history of ancient China known as the
Three Kingdoms an era in which poverty
constant wars and corrupted leaders have
thrown the entire country into chaos the
main protagonist Taotao is trying to
change the mindset of the Chinese people
so that they'll abolish outdated ideals
and ancient customs in these difficult
times he tries to bring order to the
land even if sometimes the end justifies
the means this isn't a light-hearted
anime you can expect various levels of
violence and gore when it comes to
watching it so if you've got a weak
stomach I'd recommend that you steer
clear of this anime coming in at number
nine is Lord marksman and Vanna DS the
story of Lord marksman and Vanna dis
holds a special place in the medieval
fantasy world with delightful beauties
that go in two by twos and come with
four by fours if you know what I made
the war between enemy countries is on
the rise the lands been torn apart by
illness and serious suffering the
seventh region country is one of the
most affected as it's under the ruling
of war maidens known as vanities
equipped with powerful dragon carved
weapons during the war the male
protagonist Ygritte was captured by a
beautiful maiden named Ellen Tigres
archery skills delighted her so much
that she decided to make him her servant
rather than kill him
she hoped to deploy him and his
abilities to increase her chances of
winning the war
overall Lord marksman and vana DS is a
good anime with large battles that
implement interesting strategies with
the impressive art style and animations
doing it justice along with some very
thick maidens accompanying here
you almost certainly keep your eyes
glued to the screen and if that's not
enough to convince you then let me tell
you this MC deep throats a sword
[Music]
next on our list is the heroic legend of
Arslan one of my favorites is the heroic
legend of Arslan in the year 320 the
powerful unbeatable kingdom of PARs is
at war with the neighboring Empire
Lusitania with powers seemingly not
enough to win trickery and betrayal come
into play to ensure victory thus leading
to the shameful defeat of King Andrew
Goris the third the troops from the
neighboring Lusitania led by a
mysterious warrior in a silver mask
dominate past land the fourteen-year-old
asked them the heir to the throne barely
escaped from his pursuers with the help
of his faithful Knight now he must fight
for his life and his kingdom arslan
begins a journey that'll prepare him for
the day that he'll become king but the
path to the throne is truly long and
challenging
[Music]
moving on to number seven we have the
ambition of Oda Nobu no every teenager
has had the dream of visiting his
favorite video game world however it's
hard to imagine anyone willingly
visiting dark souls in this story we
follow our 17 year old high schooler
Yoshi Haru as he wakes up and finds
himself in the middle of a raging
Sengoku period battle however for some
strange reason all the famous warriors
of that era have suddenly got the
Japanese nging and become cute anime
girls using his knowledge which he
acquired from his favorite Sengoku era
video game Nobunaga's ambition Yoshi
Haru helps no Boas retainers in
conquering Japan now if you're not gonna
watch you for the history then at least
watch it for the babes
[Music]
also one of my favorites Sengoku Basara
samurai kings comes in at number six
from massive battles to powerful
warlords that can destroy entire armies
with a single blow this story highlights
a tale of good versus evil and you may
be thinking well isn't that cliche well
it doesn't seem to be the case for this
anime at first we're presented with many
different characters who fought in
politics and arms with the hopes of
unifying the country under a central
government but eventually they put their
differences aside to fight a common
enemy the demon king of the six heavens
oda nobunaga to save feudal japan from
his tyrannical reign the story is by far
the weakest point of the series however
watching a warrior wielding six swords
with his two hands can be quite
entertaining almost like watching Zorro
from one piece working his craft halfway
to the top now and in at number five we
have the record of Grand Crest war the
joyful marriage ceremony that would
establish peace between two power blocks
eventually turns out into tragedy with
the release of chaos chaos is a dark
energy from another dimension which
brings forth monsters and demons into
the world only the lords with the power
of crests can stock chaos but they
allowed greed and pride to defeat their
common purpose and instead of fighting a
collective battle to stop chaos the
Lords fight each other for the power of
crests having witnessed the disaster
firsthand our hero in mage meets a young
warrior named Theo who is also carrying
a mysterious crest together they'll
fight battle after battle and tried to
restore balance to their war-torn land
so if you're looking for a combat
oriented adventurer with plenty of
in-depth strategizing in massive battles
and just a little touch of romance we'll
definitely find this show very
entertaining
[Music]
at number 4 is Bhutan where Oh moon oh
god that's not an easy title to say how
is it now think of a situation where
someone doesn't remember where they're
from who they are what happened to them
or why they ended up where they are now
think of that happening to you how would
you feel now you may be wondering why am
I asking these questions well if it
isn't already obvious this is exactly
what happens to our protagonist in this
story he finds himself wounded in a
village whose inhabitants have animal
ears and tails his new peaceful life in
his beloved village didn't last for long
with the start of a revolution against
the tyrannical emperor of the land
having no choice but to save and protect
the people and the village that he's
come to love hakuro will lead his men to
various battles each with epic
proportions
he must utilize some ingenious
strategies to increase their chances of
winning the war
now this anime is an emotional
rollercoaster the attractive artwork and
the excellent plot will keep you hooked
from start to finish
Oh Carol who needs mr. gorilla
the amazing berserk comes in at number
three okay so just by the name guts
you can tell who this absolute unit is
you know him your mother knows him
your grandpa knows him Hank even your
dog might know who this absolute man is
this man has gone through hardships
betrayals and even death itself but for
those who are new to animate and don't
know and get pissed off for me being so
vague here here's the general overview
this anime takes place in a high fantasy
medieval world full of evil that
overflows with Cardinal human desires of
greed and avarice as the world is
riddled with monsters the series begins
when guts joins a formidable troupe of
mercenaries the band of the hawk led by
Griffith Griffith the leader of the
troupe is an extremely ambitious man
with tremendous talents bravery and
intelligence his dream is to rule the
kingdom and as such he was prepared to
make it to reality even if it means
sacrificing anything and everything
during their escapades our main man guts
proves to be a mighty addition to
Griffiths force together they'll fight
and win many battles and just when you
think the world starts looking better
for guts the world ends up crumbling
around him as the series spirals further
into a far darker realm of fantasy
horror that could force some people to
stop watching altogether and by the way
make sure you watch the older version if
you're new to anime because there's a
new 3d version and basically don't
bother with that
we've got just one step left before we
get to the summit but to number two we
have Kingdom okay before I start this
one I've got it advise you not to lose
interest because of the poor 3d
animation in the first episodes of this
series because to be frank I did but
thankfully I had both the willpower and
the patience to carry on once you get
past the bad quality of the initial
episodes it becomes a smooth sail season
2 & 3 a much better and visual quality
and with that said let's get to the
story in the era of the warring kingdoms
China was fragmented into seven powerful
states with each trying to conquer the
other the story follows an orphaned
child named Shin shin and his best
friend both have the dream of becoming
great generals but they had no idea what
fate had in store for them they soon end
up getting separated with shins friend
getting enlisted to work in the royal
palace by a retainer of the king shin on
the other hand has to face some serious
problems including finding his friend
half dead at his doorstep he sets out to
find out who did it and why they did it
a mission that would drastically change
shins life Kingdom demonstrates some
incredibly large scale military fights
and for the most part the series did an
excellent job capturing the feel and
realities of the battlefield the manga
is one of the best-selling manga out
there so if you're not able to tolerate
the first episodes with bad animation
then try reading the manga I think this
must be the first time I've ever said
try reading the manga
nah
ring the bell and sound the alarm for
our number one entry today is the
Vinland saga at the start of the 11th
century Europe suffers from the
incessant raids of the Viking tribes the
war between England and the Danes
getting worse with each passing year
after witnessing the murder of his
father tor Finn sets out to take revenge
on the killer however his chances are
quite slim considering his young age so
he makes a long-term plan by joining the
army of his enemy this made him stronger
while plotting his revenge and preparing
himself with a perfect moment to strike
Aska lad in turn uses tor fiends
irresistible impulse to his advantage
he's entrusted him with the most
dangerous tasks with his mercenary band
of Vikings they burned villages kill
people and loot to their delight it's an
interesting story with realistic
characters in a violent yet beautifully
captured world which is brought to life
by rich colors beautiful animations and
great fights and that's it for today's
episode of the top ten list do you
believe there are some anime series that
should have made the list let me know by
leaving a comment below thanks for
watching be sure to share like and
subscribe to our Channel